this was a project to sort of explore
this area which is constantly changing
and city art has the potential to
transcend barriers that pro journalism
so this was part of the premise for this
project but it so happens that CMS W NPC
20 careless area of interest they do
things a little differently but they
both have a passionate interest in civic
art a CT I when I first came to MIT
years ago
well but she was very interested in a
lot of the same things I was interested
in as I came into the program I'm hiding
in humanistic studies so we interacted
many times in early years but since
I'll get arenas and some of the other
people and they CT then and I've always
felt so this is the second of a series
it's a four-part series just arrived
that was co-organized by AC T and C MSW
and tonight we have Daniel Bach iary
who is one of the organizers
and we will have a couple of respondents
tonight from a CT and Rick from CMS and
they will be responding to presentations
I'll turn it over to need that call
professor Balinese
so first I just wanted to thank Jim and
Marissa for their vision and looking
together this series really just
produced a new kind of center of energy
in US Open Series
Daniel
is in work beneath resilient journalist
filmmaker epidemic web developer they
will have a chance to hear of an
experience is inspiring to see music
which is been widely praised for its
creation of street performers combining
documentarians mission with a
transcultural appreciation of the
musicians the music map collaborators
are exploring that creative
possibilities left their story told
street music map mr. Granick channel
will now have more than
seven oh five and seven so it's truly an
awesome project that beautifully
promises sequences of the web mapping
technology
we're gonna experience a lot thank you
hello everyone
when I Thank You professor Jim for the
invitation it's a it's a really honor to
be here and really happy to share my
research on street music with you guys
and to start I would like to rewind 20
years and to show a little bit of my
background as a journalist and I'm the
guy with the when I be
Watergate driver you know and that was
in 1998 my journalism class and I start
as a reporter and the producer and most
I always try to cover entertainment
culture and sports and my passion on
music and four years ago I start a
project called
Street Music map my inspiration was in a
trip I was in Kiev Ukraine and I saw a
musician playing the streets I was
decided to take a picture but a few
weeks ago Instagram had the video option
so I it right
well since I'm watching a musician
playing why not making a video instead
of a picture you know
and then that was my first video about
street musicians that I post on my
personal accounts after that trip to
Ukraine
I moved from Porto Alegre in the south
of Brazil to some Paulo and since 2013 I
live near by a subway station that
usually features a lot of street
musicians around Avenida Paulista
Paulista Avenue and then I start to make
a couple of videos and uploading on my
personal Eastern Instagram account so
that time that moment the project was
Street micro ducks that was the name and
it was about pictures and videos about
street musicians I went to get some
lunch I spoke with a great friend of
mine called max LOX I show him about
this series of street musicians that I
was building on my personal account and
he told me just one single thing why
don't you open an official account to
this series don't upload them on your
personal one build your own channel
about street music and then I build
street music map as the Ephesian
incident account in late January 2014
since then more than 1400 street
musicians are already geo located on
street music map and we do have more
than four hundred four four forty one
thousand followers on Instagram
the first official post on street music
map was in January 2014
filming at Paulista Avenue
[Music]
and since the beginning I start to
sharing street musicians that I feel by
myself but on day 2 a friend of a friend
started talking to me like oh I was just
traveling I saw this musician I have a
video on my my cell phone can I send to
you and street music map episode number
12 was from Paris
and then I start to realize that Street
music nap goes beyond music you know
because I have the feedback and the
coincidence
the the person who who did who gave me
this feedback
she is from Boston and even I talked to
her today but she she has to work she
couldn't come here but the feedback that
she gave me was I was sharing several
videos from different street musicians
from several African countries and she
thanked me because she was able to teach
her students who were deaf or mute about
different cultures from the body
language of the street musicians you
know so it was not about the music it
was but it was about the body language
and here's a an example from the coast
of Ivory Coast and a seven-man then
performing in the beach
[Music]
and today here's the street music map
right now you know I update on a daily
basis and the step one was sharing the
content on Instagram step two was geo
locate the videos on Google Maps and
this geolocation I do by myself manually
so I can get accurate position of the
performance you know sometimes I don't
know where the musician actually played
and I try to figure out as a detective
in the picture you know I saw there was
a guy playing San Francisco and I saw
there was a phone number on the back
I copy/paste the phone number of Google
search in the realize oh that's he was
playing in front of this star that has
this number then I put a geo-located and
few numbers we have right now we do have
one thousand and four hundred and nine
videos there is a lot of street
musicians from Brazil US UK Italy
Germany and France and until now 97
countries are already represented into
the map when you talk about cities there
is some Paolo New York London Rio Austin
in Paris and Asti owns a lot to solve by
Southwest that's the moment where the
musicians go to the streets in Asti and
go out from the venules you know and
then I realized to identify some
Geographic patterns relating music and
avenues and subways so if you take New
York City is all about subway stations
pug squares in parks when it's not cold
London the same Paris as well so we do
have a pattern in these big cities with
a healthy public system of
transportation and in New York we do
have the MTA music it's organization
from the subway in London we do have the
berski berski London program that's
related to the mayor of London and in
Paris it's the organization related to
the subway as well if you take some
power for example Istanbul and Melbourne
we do have these large avenues business
this business commercial districts that
we that's where the musician the street
musicians feel more comfortable to play
you know so there is a new pattern you
can see in these three big cities around
the world there is an example of Rio de
Janeiro New Orleans and Los Angeles
it's about specific regions you know Rio
de Janeiro it's its South Side it's by
the beach and downtown if you go to New
Orleans it's about the French district
if you go to LA it's about Santa Monica
Pier and Santa Monica prominent and you
see when you don't have a powerful
subway system you need to go where
people are passing by right so you take
these examples that's by the beach or
this unique example of New Orleans that
there's this entire city and this
beautiful neighborhood that's all about
music
we have about Boston I start to
geolocate musicians in Boston and we can
realize that Harvard Square Boston
Common and the subway stations
you can see a lot of street musicians in
Boston in Cambridge
here's a number that I need to share
because this number demands a whole
symposium about it
we have 1409 videos geo-located around
the planet this represents only 10% of
male artists this is surreal
this is bizarre and I thought this
number well this is just like a sample
you know I don't have the whole planet
in the map but when I go outside and
when I share this number with expertise
on music in street music in culture the
feedback that I hear I have this like
yep it's pretty much this maybe is not
10 maybe 15 but if it's not 50/50
something is really wrong you know so
and I start to realize you know like I
was playing with my Excel you know like
let's see which more information I can
get from here hmm let's do the
male/female stats you know and then I
realize that's not good
besides they Street music map featuring
street musicians in each P I started to
identify street music festivals and
there's really there's two big sources
here that I'd like to share is a site
called busker Centro and a project
called the busking project and we do
have 100 at least
176 events around planet about street
music and you see that Europe in North
America illustrates a lot and when you
talk about countries there is Australia
where represented
and of course I really want to get deep
into Asia in Africa after the maps after
the Instagram last year I was able to
attend program at CUNY in New York I
intrapreneur journalism program called
the top the tonight and I was able to
study New York for six months and to
start to interview the street musicians
in the streets so I built a create a
podcast called Street Music map radio so
it all right there are short talks about
street musicians where I do interview
the musician in the street I record them
playing live in the streets and if they
do have some material from studio I add
it into an episode I'd like to share one
of one of these episodes with Alice
timidly singer from New York and I added
a short cut here I will call her
performing on Time Square and then I
booked an interview with her nearby her
house in Harlem
so I recall her in a park it was in a
Sunday afternoon and let's see if we if
you can listen
[Music]
she's seen the entire square
I
years
she's seen the acapella Harlan
[Music]
and then from the podcast I start to
identify the street musicians with
material on Spotify so I start to create
playlists customized playlists featuring
street musicians from different
countries in different cities and these
were the first playlist is about street
music own spot on Spotify itself few
years ago I was curating a Street Music
Festival in San Paulo they invite me to
select some street bands to play in a
public square called la rue droite ocean
in downtown Sao Paulo and we decided to
produce an album recorded live in the
streets so there was a street music
festival and we were recording the
performance life in each band we
recorded nine bands and I would like to
show one of the live cuts here
[Music]
this band is called who Grange a group
of ehh
he's a street band from Brazil and this
song was recorded live in a public
square in some hall and sometimes we
forget that or some of our biggest idols
they start in the street as well you
know you get examples like BB King Eric
Clapton James Joplin jay-z they started
their career in these streets you know
so sweet music map is looking for the
icons you know for the future and in the
last year's I start to identify some
pretty awesome performance you know I
remember that actually in 2014 I share
one of the videos of this musician from
Melbourne called - Sultana and here I'm
sharing a video from YouTube from 2050
she was playing in Brook Street that
Street that I showed in the map few
slides ago here she is she's playing in
2015
[Music]
[Music]
and here she's playing Lollapalooza 2080
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and a few weeks ago she was in Time
Square in the ad
brought to you by Spotify like the new
big deal because she's brilliant and
then we have an example this is a video
I made in Union Square January 2017
too many zoos is the band they the
awards they played four years at Union
Square and this was last year
[Music]
[Music]
and then a few months after they produce
a music video of fish of one
[Music]
and the reaction was huge and Google
really liked them as well so they became
Google soundtrack for the new pixel it
was this was like January then March
than me
they were playing Union Square and they
became Google we had music in this one
one of the greatest new ones pianists
and composers Benjamin Clemente was
playing 2011 in the in Paris na Metro in
the Metro
[Applause]
[Music]
and then he went to Joe Stalin on BBC on
2013 and
[Music]
and he was discovered by a by a
headhunter like who saw him playing Bob
Marley cover in Paris and he got called
to return to UK
he's from UK he started to recording and
the first big appearance was in Jose
Holland and on that year 2013 he won a
Mercury Prize for best new new name
about the next steps on street music map
one goal is to develop the map you know
putting more features you can find more
about these street musicians you know
you can share more about each one you
can get musicians and fans connected
wherever they are and if you have a
model its global audience to local
artists and one of my dreams is to
produce a 24 hour Street Music Man
festival a live streaming concert from
24 cities in 20 countries won't line up
per hour
one per CD going full circle around the
planet you know we can mix streaming we
can mix smartphones we can use social
network in the best way possible and you
can build an audience wherever you are
being an artist wherever you play
it's all about collab more than 700
people already share and already hashtag
street music map on social networks and
that's why we do have a map featuring
more than one thousand and four hundred
street musicians
my closest friends my closest partners
into this project
Teodoro Marcus is the guy responsible
for the design he's the one who built
the logo martini rebellion is the one
who built the second version of the
street music map site that's it's a work
in progress right now and to finish my
my talk here I would like to play a
short doc about busking and it was
recorded in Brazil a few years ago in a
festival called festival path I was able
to curate the street music stage and I
interview a couple of street musicians
they speaking Portuguese but we do have
the subtitle in English here
[Music]
[Music]
ah see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
I need to listening thank you so much I
liked about your presentation is that
it's so generative and generous and
you're such a good champion of people
and media to give are both cultural
producers here
moments and basing it very carefully
with myths she's on the board of
directors of the gallery
uprising from the media
rhythm of traffic
I was a DJ producer a curator and
educator
Rico was a sound designer in the Tony
award-winning original
and I raided a few two worlds she's done
remixes for a number of artists
including Meredith brent has performed
at Obama's White House and
internationally
she's a master's candidate here in CMAs
so first I'll have Lara
then we'll have Rica and and then we'll
look thank you
so forth
[Music]
[Music]
it's also
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
your speech
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and it also drew attention to me the
challenges as we see venues and spaces
and documents
that was noticeable to me it's also
noticeable or it breaks the attention
even though
just I was also curious in the sense of
like in New York City there is a
official program you said in London as
well as Paris that there are some states
endorsed programs for music but there
also others and the criminalization
we reminded that public space
as well and you know I'm just curious to
see the girl and the exchange is not
only between the musicians and its
trajectory or successive
commercialization has been the case but
also the connection between thank you
very much
[Applause]
so guys feel free yep
there's I do a lot of body language to
not interrupt the act you know so of
course if you are in the streets
nowadays lot of people are fuming right
so there is something that I do sees
they want even though I know there are a
lot of people don't ask to start filming
I do and that's make all the difference
it's not like you you can be playing the
drums you know and I get and then he
knows all he knows that I am exists you
know that I'm not like like I like I am
NOT icon I'm not in a circus you know
I'm not in the zoo
yeah there's there's Rizzo please in
some Paulo it's it's a very very core
part of some Paulo but really strong
culturally so there are some bands that
play in Paulista that they already there
they also play in the peripheral area
but that's true it's in some Paulo we do
have it's highly concentrated in one big
Avenue and we there is a lack of street
music seen in other areas you know or
not the media doesn't go there you know
how do I find I find if I have the
chance to travel I reach the musician in
the street and I ask them to record and
I film and I share but I do a lot of
digital research so if I find a street
musician with a material on Instagram or
YouTube
I don't just share right away I get in
touch with the musician I ask them if I
can share or I ask the person who film
so I try to credit everybody you know
the filmmaker and the musician in the
beginning I was not sharing if I didn't
know the name of the musician was like
I'm not going to share this but then I
realized that a community was being
built and I start to get help from news
from followers like oh there is a
musician drummer playing in Paulista I
didn't have the name and someone
commented hey I know the guy his name is
this you know and then I updated the
credit and I start to do this you
like a lot of I do have I do have a lot
of help from the followers to build and
to upgrade the content
yeah I'm glad to say that the feedback
is is really good you know and since I
once I once I identify the musicians I
try to follow the social network
accounts you know so I get updates from
everybody and several times I can see
like people communicating
you know after it was posted on street
music map you know a producer or a new
fan or a band connecting with another
band you know
so I from there is a 360 communication
going on you know from offline to online
and to offline again you know
yes hi maybe maybe I have a different
sense of busky for me busking is street
music so like if the only rule that I
made for myself in this projects like
has to be in the street playing some
music you know for example for instance
during the World Cup in Brazil 2014
I share a lot of soccer supporters
singing the streets you know so there is
like British fans singing the subway in
in Brazil there are supporters from from
Algeria cheering in Algiers and III I
caught the moment so there's this huge
party in public square in Algiers and I
share like and there I and I put like
artists equals Algerian fans after ago
you know because they were singing so
like it's about it is about music I'm
not I'm not
select I'm not filtering other arts be
made own streets because that was a
choice in the beginning or like I'm
gonna I'm gonna choose this huge future
that's music already then that's that
that's how that's why I became street
music map and back in in the beginning
was Street micro docks
[Music]
there is there is one project that III I
quote in one of these lights called the
busking project it's created by Nick
broad he is North American he lives in
Bogota right now and he is busking
project
gathers a lot of street music law
guidance you know and about laws
regarding street music is not every
country is like every little town has a
different law about if you if you can't
play or if you don't I get a lot of
feedback from street musicians in Europe
that someone from Portugal that decides
to play in a small town in Italy and
there's like a post oh man I just got
fined 100 euros I didn't know because
that little town you're not supposed to
play in that particular
yeah yeah like like on Facebook and
Twitter like people try to hey guys if
you go to this little tout please don't
play in here by the hospital but yeah
the tricky part it's like every town has
a different law but we do have
particular sites that are aware about
the laws and there's a festival
happening right now in some of you
called hunk festival and it's a strict
activist festival they do care a lot
about street musicians and about the
laws and what you can do you know what
you can't you know
yeah in some pologize
there is a group called sample it's
called artistís nahua and street artists
they do dialog a lot with the mayor's
office in some problem and this thing
that it's happening in Paulista Avenue
Avenue des Avenida Paulista is sample
this is new is like from a couple of
years ago maybe four or five years ago
because six years ago you were not able
to play in Paulista Avenue without
getting fine
yep every no no I they they send I get a
lot of videos I search a lot and get in
touch of the musician are so happens
both ways and then I film and of course
there's a curation you know I I am I am
the last filter before sharing but you
know because sometimes technically the
video is not interesting but on the
other hand the fun part and the sharp is
about being raw
I don't like over produce it you know if
over producer you don't feel this sweet
you know because the I think me as a
follower you know I like to travel
around the world by watching the watch
it sample you know and if you have like
that how do you say vote voyeurism yeah
like you like kind of you feel like
something that strolling image you like
something happening that you feel like
they're you know but he's not strolling
yeah yeah for sure
yes I try to power the social networks
you know and I try to announce and try
to yeah to promote to promote the the
research and the platform in different
different ways to to people so the
musicians can can share new material
with me and if they if you like it they
can then I share I always ask if they
they are cool to share you know em
sometimes that's that's a that's a fun
an adduct and I'm kind of proud I just
had to turn down one video it was a
cover there was a couple of of singers
performing kiss from Prince and I got a
I got an email from pins princes sister
from new power generation
she said you cannot upload the Prince
and I said really
two excellent singers because they love
you can't there was the only one and you
know a sweet music nap
and you know there there is no brand
attachment so like it is a opendata
you know but sometimes these things
happens and this was it was before and
I'm I love Chris and it was before him
passed away and probably he he was one
one of the big ones that was always
searching
the moments of celebration are the
pumpkin swear
yeah that's that's one of the best bar
talks that we can have it and I I
totally agree it said these damned
wallet see you know it's like do you
sell your soul for the devil or not you
know yeah and uh yeah I I agree I agree
it's comes natural like what what is
glory right and and and getting York
getting a link for your thought one of
the most positive feedbacks that I get
from street musicians and for that last
but not least they are musicians because
sometimes always street musicians oh and
then musicians now musicians just a
different stage you know is a different
platform but they do the same thing they
are the same thing and what one of the
most interesting feedbacks that people
who goes to to the street to play
because that's where they have the most
honest feedback from the audience
because if you stop by to listen to
someone and you have another appointment
there's a connection a connection is
built and I heard from a lot of
musicians that oh tomorrow I'm gonna try
a new material we're in the street
because if someone pay attention maybe I
get I I got a good riff you know if the
if if no one stops buys maybe I need to
work out a little more you know so
that's the fun of it yeah
I think it's a good idea do you guys
would like to listen to some street
musicians right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you